mix and match the cdc has given the
green light for residents to mix their
covid19 vaccines all three current
brands are safe according to medical
experts christian casares joining us
live in studio and christian do we know
if you get more or less protection from
essentially doing this mix-up well brian
we spoke to an epidemiologist at unlv
today and he tells us all three have
different sequences but at the end of
the day our bodies react to them in the
same way this was a step that was
expected as things continue to evolve
as we roll into the colder months of the
year the cdc is urging people to get the
flu vaccine as well as the covet 19 shot
the centers for disease control and
prevention says the mixing of vaccine
brands is permitted and will cause no
harm pfizer moderna and johnson and
johnson are currently the only approved
brands we spoke to an epidemiologist at
unlv nearly every mix and match
combination resulted in an increase in
antibodies some more than others but
sometimes that increase really doesn't
mean anything so i think we're still
learning about it and it's hard to say
if you got this vaccine first you should
get this one second because that's the
best protection and the target's
changing as well when we started doing
this delta didn't exist regarding
booster shots labis says the cdc is open
to mixing vaccine brands but is not
pushing for it he says the protection is
the same
another good reminder coveted vaccines
are not currently an annual shot at this
point so if you are eligible for the
booster shot he recommends it as we wait
for guidance from the cdc on this issue
christian costa is live local now